au coeur du quartier chinois le nouvel
an aura encore une fois des allures
modestes un petit peu tranquille avec ma
petite famille mais justement acheter
du porc au barbecue pour pour manger
ensemble en famille on a quelque chose à
manger aux rays au papier chinois parce
que je suis d'origine chinoise on va
manger on fait réunion la maison c'est
comme qu'est ce que comme en ont fêté
noël
[Musique]
selon le membre du comité de la relance
des cuisines du quartier chinois wang
qishan le nouvel an reste maître du tout
un moment marquant pour les communautés
chinoises à montréal et partout au
canada cette année c'est l'année du tse
et linguistique symbolise le courage
nous si la force de pouvoir surpasser
les trois obstacles et les défis ils ont
été nombreux au cours des deux dernières
années il ya un an à peu près où la
pandémie il ya eu des actes de
vandalisme raciste d entrée par
effraction et des fenêtres sont brisées
au centre d'achats ici
les restaurateurs chinois souvent
associé à la pandémie se relève peu à
peu après plusieurs fermetures c'est le
cas des doigts recours qui dit avoir
tiré son épingle du jeu grâce aux
réseaux sociaux c'était difficile harper
c'est sûr on a trouvé un autre moyen de
façon d'adapter avec la pandémie et tout
temps nos débuts en auto nissan à ses
fans mais on est très heureux
aujourd'hui et on va arrêter ce soir
après travaille aussi sur l'iphone dans
un autre les tables étaient déjà remplis
en après midi
et à la proche de la grande cérémonie
d'ouverture à pékin wilkinson se sent
fier mais se questionne sur la façon
dont sera perçu la chine après les jeux
on sait pas comment ça va comment la
communauté fait
s'il
vous reste encore cette nouvelle année
lunaire on se souhaite de façon quasi
unanime bonne santé pas de co vite ici
gabriel pro radio canada montréal
un extraordinaire spectacle de lumières
seule parcelle de normalité des
festivités du nouvel an lunaire les
célébrations traditionnelles elles se
déroulent sans les food habituels
resserrement des mesures sanitaires
confinement restrictions sur les
déplacements la recrudescence des codes
que vides gâche les fêtes du nouvel an
lunaire en chine pour une troisième
année
le gouvernement chinois prévoit un
milliard deux cents millions de voyages
pendant cette période fériée on est loin
des 3 milliards observés en 2019 de
nombreuses familles chinoises ne peuvent
retourner festoyer dans leur région
natale
c'est la première fois que cette femme
n'ira pas voir sa famille dans la
province de hunan
celle-ci 108 sa famille mais elle
n'oserait pas voyager en ce moment
dans la bulle olympique décoration et
activités du nouvel an des célébrations
particulières pour les bénévoles chinois
isolé comme les athlètes et journalistes
ce sera quand même plus animé que dans
ma famille se réjouit-il
celle-ci se console en se disant qu'elle
est entourée d'amis et les gens venus de
partout découvrir son pays
elle partage d'ailleurs l'esprit de la
fête à l'atelier de calligraphie du
centre des médias les gens y trace
l'idéogramme qui signifie le bonheur les
visiteurs peuvent s'initier aux
traditions du nouvel an lunaire on doit
ensuite accroché ce bout de papier rouge
soit une porte ou une fenêtre afin
d'inviter la bonne fortune et la chance
au cours de l'année qui commence dans
les villages olympiques festin et autres
activités pour les athlètes même dans la
bulle aseptisée
ils ont l'esprit à la fête et tente
d'exprimer quelques voeux au mandat
l'année du tigre comment ce symbole de
force et de joie présage selon certains
d'une meilleure année pour plusieurs
athlètes les festivités vont continuer
médaille au cou il sait philippe leblanc
radio-canada pékin